el dueño de un restaurante desea saber
más acerca de los lugares de origen de
sus clientes un día decidió recolectar
información acerca de la distancia en
millas que la gente recorría para llegar
a su restaurante la gente respondió las
siguientes distancias recorridas y aquí
tenemos todas las distancias que le
dieron los clientes que recorren él
quiere crear una gráfica que le ayude a
entender el rango de las distancias y la
mediana o que esto es importante tenemos
dos datos que nos están pidiendo
y el rango nos está dando una clave
porque es información muy importante
mientras que tenemos que la mediana
también es un dato que vamos a tener
qué tipo de gráfica debería de crear
bueno de hecho la pregunta de qué tipo
de gráfica debería de crear es como muy
directa y eso lo podemos contestar no
solo vamos a saber qué tipo de gráfica
vamos a ocupar sino que también la
haremos y la pregunta sería qué tipo de
gráfica nos va a dar tanto los rangos
como la mediana de una manera visual de
tal manera que este dueño del
restaurante pueda tener toda su
información en un solo vistazo pues el
tipo de gráfica que hemos de crear será
una gráfica de caja y bigotes
así es que pues empezaremos a graficar
de acuerdo a los datos que tenemos para
lograr encontrar la mediana primero
vamos a utilizar esta información pero
es importante que para sacarla primero
pongamos en orden toda esta información
así es que vamos a ir número por número
y busquemos cuál es el número más
pequeño que tenemos en toda esta base de
datos
tenemos un 1 aquí
y colocaremos uno
tenemos otro uno
2 tenemos 12
tenemos algún otro dos si aquí hay otro
3 sería el siguiente
algún otro 3 si aquí están
4 aquí hay un 4
aquí hay otro 4
tenemos 5
no no tenemos 56
7 hay algún 7 si aquí hay un 7
88 aquí hay 18
no hay 9 tenemos aquí un 10
12 13 14
y 22
para que nosotros encontremos la mediana
recuerda que podemos tomar la
clasificación de si son números pares o
nones en este caso tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 datos dado
que entonces 17 su número no buscaremos
la mediana que nos dirá que hay la mitad
de números son más pequeños que esta y
la mitad de números son más grandes que
ésta es decir tendremos 8 números hacia
la izquierda
nuestra mediana y ocho números hacia la
derecha porque justo está en el centro
de la información vamos a ponerle
entonces con este color rosa que hemos
marcado previamente y el 6 será la
mediana
este será el número que nosotros
utilizaremos como mediana para nuestra
gráfica ya que tenemos la mediana todo a
nuestro bloque de datos se ha dividido
ahora en dos grandes porciones tenemos
la porción a la izquierda y la porción a
la derecha la convención nos dice que
para armar esta gráfica de caja y
bigotes lo que haremos es buscar ahora
la mediana del lado izquierdo y la
mediana del lado derecho para eso
entonces contamos la cantidad de datos
que tenemos y volveremos a buscar justo
la parte central tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
8 datos por lo tanto cuando tenemos
números pares lo que hemos de buscar es
entre los dos números centrales cuál es
el promedio de estos en este caso
tenemos 2 y 3 si sumamos 2 + 3 tendremos
5 y entre 2 nos dará 2.5
2.5
haremos exactamente lo mismo del otro
lado tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 datos por
lo tanto la mitad estaría aquí 4 y 4 los
2 números que tomaremos para sacar la
mediana de este bloque serán el 11 y el
14 11 + 14 son igual a 25 25 entre 2 es
igual a 12.5
y de esta manera tendremos la mediana
del bloque del lado derecho y ahora que
tenemos entonces toda la información
podemos empezar con la gráfica para ello
haré una recta numérica tomaré algún
color que no hayamos usado y haré una
recta numérica
nos hemos de asegurar que esta recta
numérica vaya del 0 hasta el número más
grande que tenemos en nuestra base de
datos en este caso tenemos 22 digamos
que aquí tendremos 5
este será pies
y la gráfica pudiera seguir sin embargo
nosotros solo ocuparemos hasta el 22
vamos entonces a marcar donde se
encuentran cada uno de estos puntos para
que podamos hacer nuestra gráfica
tenemos la mediana del bloque del lado
izquierdo que hemos visto de forma
separada en 2.5 de 05 tendremos aquí 2.5
vamos a considerarlo aquí mientras que
del lado derecho tendremos la mediana de
este bloque en 12.5
que más o menos estará por aquí 12.5
vamos a colocarlo 12.5 vamos a poner
este punto que casi no se ve
ahora este
será el bloque donde se encuentre la
gran mayoría de los datos que nosotros
estamos utilizando
y para que también nosotros podamos
marcar con mayor exactitud será
importante mostrar dónde se encuentran
la mediana del total del universo que
estamos manejando en este caso tenemos
la mediana en el número 6
y estará por aquí
podemos colocarlo así y con esto tenemos
la parte de la caja de nuestra gráfica
ahora nuestra gráfica se llama caja y
bigotes los bigotes serán la extensión
que nos marca hasta qué punto tenemos el
dato más pequeño y el dato más grande es
decir en el rango recuerdan que aquí
estábamos solicitando el rango pues esta
es la manera en la que podemos descubrir
lo nuestro rango va desde el 1 hasta el
22 así es que si lo marcamos en la
gráfica por aquí tendremos el 1
y el 22 estará por aquí
si subimos estos puntos
podemos decir que nuestra gráfica
quedará de la siguiente manera
donde tenemos un rango del 1 al 22 con
la mediana en el número 6 y marcando en
esta caja donde se encuentra la gran
mayoría de los datos y visualmente con
eso hemos contestado la pregunta del
dueño del restaurante con una gráfica de
caja y bigotes